all right welcome everybody
we've just waiting here just a little
bit getting everything set up hopefully
everything is in order now
Jonathan shruts and I'll be playing the
people today so if you are challenging
us on my chest and someone's gonna put a
link in the the chats here which I'm
reading right next to me
go ahead challenge me I think a
five-minute game would be a good way to
start off the stream so whatever you
guys are doing challenge st. Louis chess
club here on lis chess and maybe we'll
get to play a game there's also probably
some tech stuff so let's just play a
game against somebody and we'll make
sure everything is all set up right so I
don't I see a three minute game which
we'll just start off with and hope for
the best here so thank you everybody for
joining us hi Adi who's playing in the
Karin's Cup you can now go check that
out on US chess champs calm they got the
whole field so it is published if you
guys are interested in seeing everybody
that is playing so that's the next big
event I believe the opening ceremony is
on February 5th and then the 6th is the
round one game all right we got it
Kings Indian here and
[Music]
so I guess easy yeah Queen d2 is
probably a bad move but what can you do
yeah d4 was played yeah good to see you
Daniel good to see you just add blue
yeah d2 was probably a mistake
cuz now when he goes to c5 he's gonna
add pressure here and what am I gonna do
play Queen c2 and waste time probably
yeah really the Queen should be on c2
and then my knight can head back to d2
at some point if I need to probably the
optimal way but hey it's Caleb Denby
yeah we're live you want to join us yeah
I admit this move was a mistake not
playing well first just making sure it
does appear to be good let us know if
there's any audio or or video images
that are wrong what's the weather says
Albert oh it's actually starting to get
cold today the high is about is it's
about like 20 degrees Fahrenheit and
it's going to be something like a high
of two tomorrow or something like that
something crazy it's gonna be really
cold we got a wind chill coming in so
it's been okay okay being in the 40s and
well yeah it's about to get really cold
alright so I've made a series of random
moves here and we're just playing some
game we're playing
awesome playing some chess keep making
random moves I think that's the funniest
there's my deep positional idea though
g4 h5 he's gonna go here lock it up
super deep when it's gonna be very
strategically successful okay it's
microphone number two for the day I'm
gonna move my mic lean as much as
possible as well right that is key in
one person so last I heard you guys were
replacing me with the GM today yeah I
didn't really know what was happened
that was all Danny with schukat rumor so
you know you got to take that with a
grain of salt oh okay
at 7 p.m. in your country Alberto can
only imagine where that would be
east of here how you doing Caleb
I'm doing good how's the game this is
Game one yeah yeah we're just starting
here and you know just playing some
random stuff gets victory up Joe the
rating on the club count is much higher
than I remember
that's good someone's been doing well I
think we should have the GM do it last
is that what happened that would make
sense hopefully that's what happened so
we got to get higher though when we 1972
who many Isaac trans trans either one
tearing us down
I think well he does one minute this is
gonna be blissful yeah we're gonna be
doing blitz today so yeah do challenge
us something like five minutes would be
ideal because I just want to talk and I
want to look at chat almost Forks almost
works yeah yeah you can watch the game
I'm gonna watch the chat we'll do the
opposite of what makes sense right okay
I think that's the funnier way to tilt
this towards me so it's harder for you
good take that look at that I do a
tactic kind of alright just add blue
ones to play
sure well wait he says do my challenge
but then he added someone else maybe he
doesn't want to lay them yeah yeah
someone else pleiad interested blue dude
you really can't tell who's de journee
list all of the cans type players from
memory yeah don't come I think it's
better if they go and look at it cuz I'm
gotta say all the regulations and
everything what is it February 5th US
chess champs calm let's just check made
somebody coming
don't check madam
I don't know I looked over and I thought
you were winning so I kind of stopped
you dear thank you 95 Oh check it took
the computer a while to recognize that
as a check yeah will you take it if you
play up d3 they miss you oh yeah I was
gone for a little bit I was gone for a
little bit but I am back that's good to
be back yeah I didn't get to play last
week cuz I was on vacation and the
problem is I don't think next week we
get to play there because it's gonna be
Karen scope and stuff yeah this is your
club free or you need to pay it is a
member based Club first visits free so
you never been here just come check it
out yeah yeah you always get the first
visit free well it's 7 p.m. in his
country so it's gonna be yeah might be
quite the trip oh yeah it's worth it
it's worth it just say you you heard
about it on streem everybody at ones
chess openings explain even me I
understand yes some questions about the
timing off you know in a good time and
I'm sure that's that's all week I've
been a big huge time enough player I'm
really good at it so people love the
Sicilian while give it a go that usually
does the trick
it made a sound I got I got scared I got
really scared ah see it makes it scary
sounds yeah also we got changed it
sounds good does anybody like to sound
also I got to win on time there now it's
like the video game didn't go that way
that showed me that was good technique
there does this threaten just another
trick before us I can subway oh boy it's
actually playing fast no
maybe I shouldn't have done this maybe
easy win easy win Thank You Victor
Gaucho I'm super GM and they'll pay you
to come that's true that's true you
don't even have to be super please do
you're opening this with that amazing
raagh you spelled wrong wrong
random opening generator Oh all right
let's even find a five-minute game it's
casual come on I want your reading point
sweet we should set some reading goal
all right here's the only one let's
start off tough this is gonna be too
hard for me oh my god you do I think two
draws in one loss I don't know if that
was actually meet up okay it's gonna be
tough one so just as long as she doesn't
play my my kryptonite thank which
because I have to take cause it's
impossible not to take and then I just
lose my plan is typically just to lose
in this line will you play it like me
yeah a 4 if we're OK 3 cuz that's what
they do in correspondence and your
computer says so but you know Magnus is
good so he plays Queen e2 yeah yeah yeah
no I always get crushed when they play
this no I could say it's the one thing I
hate to face
I'm not as good so I put like magnets or
have been doctored you play Queen e2
probably the right way I've always
played rook a 300 from England you are
cold I am all twirl everybody is cold
it's freezing everywhere in there thank
you we're just going go private always
put the Queen here for some reason I
don't know what what was the windshield
supposed to be today like - today is
like ok because we're comparing it to
the future days they're coming up OK
didn't you come here and you go what's
going on yeah
more pawns more space it's probably
always maybe that's not the optimal
square for a bishop there's no way to
know
well you might put it on the seat
through you some trade guys go in there
or this and this is happening it's
always a thing things report Shh I
wouldn't say anything
oh you missed he just says Queen a6
Jonah a six a six he ran away quite a
bit he ran away quite a bit get out
did you not have a good square to go to
I was always scary
why just cuz he could check me out there
yes this happens and then something on
this thing will happen six or a five or
you know I live on the edge gave it a
second rank go here I wish I knew where
this guy lived if anywhere that guy
blonde I'd put him there yeah but I
don't
Jimmy just each one is you know he
doesn't have great ambitions just each
one for this thing it is cold
everybody's cold
alright now to take this with the
optimal peace Spain wants to trade yeah
he does
yeah usually it doesn't matter that I
grew up upon because it's Banco but
usually that just doesn't mean anything
I'm gonna deal with 96 why is it noisy
playing in Karen's cup I know the answer
what if I can say the answer but yeah
she has another opportunity well yes so
she's actually or maybe she's too lairy
for that one she is I think the only one
for the championship the US Championship
that won't be playing so she won't be
playing in the women's so I think I can
go here because of she's got a lot of
stuff going on in her life that's
probably better financially and
otherwise mmm going on so knight c6
somehow 94 you can't save either so why
bother where you want to go 94 you had a
defend of work and also 96
why is this pawn wait court might have
fun go three degrees Celsius in Poland
like we've got that beat tomorrow
probably what is to zero 32 so I mean
it's below that hello a Denon gaming see
he's got too many good options here too
much stuff he could take so he's
confused get in there
Go Go no tank okay now I'll push your
puns fast enough oh come on I challenged
you and the 1578 what a player higher
than that
I demand Katarina nem solo me too
well we just have so many wonderful
players that we can't let them all play
[Music]
take it dorms about to Queen and I
didn't yeah you confused me yeah
just blame him hello random kid hello
the truth I see yeah you notice who I am
yeah if you guys know that Knights
receives lots of llamas in the chat for
some reason cuz I learned that's a thing
that you can do yeah didn't work out
please take it okay wait take on b8 and
186 and then maybe something for the
best teenage thing it you were really
close though feels like checkmate at
almost yeah too tough too strong for me
kappa blanka any King I can't play I
can't be kappa blanka I think that's
what we knew say hi to Turkey a lot of
people are in Turkey button down despite
the cold weather I have to open up my
jacket to get the to get the mic on hmm
I never plan on what shirt I'm wearing
because it's like it doesn't matter and
then I you know my stream have to open
it up I'm like oh yeah so I guess it
matters what shirt I wear alright let's
make it easier Batman Begins
come on me take it easy
so are you a turkey or not oh oh this
old there's one way far away say hi the
turkey it's Ricky a lot of people who
are in Turkey
like you man thank you very much that's
good to know I'm big in Turkey alright
were goes in because that's that's what
you're playing right yeah so this is a
hundred percent how you gonna get a play
from now on oh no that's not what that's
not the movements effort that is what
the super teams play but okay we're
doing here Oh probably see five it's
impossible to take stuff play in the
middle yeah I do hello chess King
Jonathan we should play I challenged you
your name is Arden Dirk's even I can't
read it's too far away
mmm if I go here I get forked done some
billion move don't get forth don't get
for it I can't I can't remember the name
of that series we are accepting
challenges I think 3 + 2 + 5 + so our
ideal
what's happening here go away
I think he's gonna go away we'll see I
think I could play here he's gonna go
here when it's gonna top away somewhere
and I'm just gonna haul the best and my
bottle doing on which one are you
worried about both of them okay I trust
your judgment develop your stuff yeah
we're like threatened mate somehow okay
and then you said something then you can
bring the rook and then hello Richie
room top
is there only 90 person instead of in
spite of 300,000 yeah but he said stuff
um I am doing it okay what'd you say
okay your pond hangs where everywhere
which one all of them would swear I put
it's checkmate okay for sure yeah you
didn't take nothing oh yeah we should
change the board sounds after this game
yeah that's I was come on do you know
how to do it yeah oh god he's gonna for
me you wanna do in the middle of the
game it's more exciting right
isn't that more exciting so just click
your name and then click sound
preference no sound yeah I was in
preferences earlier what school standard
Oh what have I done to the board it's
fine just don't scroll down standard it
was pentatonic so people are - oh no
that one's weird whoa I take it back I
take it back I apologize the board
sounds make it makes us sound like space
invaders yeah why are men in my shoes
great name
okay some random position yeah this
looks very boring perfect way I like it
you gotta stop all the pawn breaks oh my
god just up nothing we do nothing nope
no undeveloped go checkmate him
this is all part of the check mating
attack and all of the rooks into the
game I only know the one language and I
barely know that I only Jonathan knows
any other languages
he lived in Spain for a while so he only
knows English so I only know English I
just don't tell anyone I speak Spanish
sure they'll make me do it
maybe call Cuba once ask him wouldn't uh
kappa blanka memorial was and that's
what I learned don't let people know
do you understand Spanish leave that to
Dennis yeah yeah Dennis Thoreau is the
only one that speaks another language we
promised random oof just finish on
YouTube we're the best that could be
directed at my co partner though who
also has great videos on YouTube it's
true overnight what are you doing I'm
gonna stop reading all the compliments
to you because you know I'm just gonna
send them back your way it feels
disingenuous when I say my loan but ciao
sounds like it's gonna happen huh
dang it
first and just to get someone's name
know what that that really means
it's weird I didn't get to take his
queen for free uh hmm just at some point
like now just kidding I know you really
want me to swing my Brooks oh I know
yeah but no you've got pawns in the way
okay I'll get him out the way okay so
you want before if they're in the way
I'll get him out the way only Spanish I
know is there Roy oh c'mon don't lose no
problem says alright
turning the curtains wants to play us
before he goes back to work okay but I
don't know what darn be Kearns Lee chess
name is he probably told us already tell
us again darn him occurrence
it's probably dharna be huh where is it
darn be darn it be is that you check out
check you out plus there's a second darn
be y'all to remind make us hey you took
a thing wait it but those are with more
than night's know what it thought okay
no for some move not your peep on I hate
my people your beep on hate my people
the puns are dumb yeah what's hoping to
go here yeah just didn't happen that way
well you can still go that still go here
yeah please gonna take a knee take all
right I knew it
I'm a genius come on Jonathan don't lose
I promise nothing don't do it no I'm
also interested here at lose and then
everybody's happy you guys beat me and
you can get to run around town saying
yeah I crushed him on the Internet
Batman Begins strikes again
all right Thank You Batman I don't think
I've gone through a single stream
without seeing Batman Begins he's
dedicated a good game
darn abhi where you at five plus two oh
goodness
alright so what should we talk about I
don't know there's so much time alright
we're going to you for throw that up on
the board
good game oh this is for you
wait a second wait what's the most
nonsensical thing I can do uh you want
to know what alpha 0 plays yeah yeah d 4
D 3 D 3 or maybe it's that you know you
guys friends in real life 9 f 3 9 f 3
all right what it's what it's what
Thanks that's it's like this end game
sucks for you for black for black
because of reasons
oh the reasons next move now develop my
stuff make up a four okay it's the quiet
strong the classic restricting pond okay
that's strong five this is easy just as
easy this is how alpha plays huh this is
what Jacob Wilkins tells me Jacobs tells
you that alpha plays liszt it's what he
tells me
mm-hm just keep going or you stopping it
that's right now else would be too much
he's restricted okay this pawn is the
tech
off his best piece but this porn aspect
yeah so he wonder if there should be
three maybe just got like Bishop III I
got double puns
those are weak yes yeah okay this is how
you play this is how you play it yeah
you're a goat if I match with you guys
online I would resign before starting
perfect I want to play you alright
laptop man wants to play s and so does I
mean I assume if you challenged us you
want to play us so I assume there's 15
people here it's 15 people in the queue
assume they all my place yeah but
someone want to play so badly they'll
get on the chair talk about it that's
true at least you in the trip is that a
new gambit I don't think it's a gambit
yeah I've confused artemiy this is the
power of so I gotta remember this is a
game in a long time we got in there we
can just chill out for a long time stuff
c3 this is still theory you're gonna
complain that this is still theory why
is your night on an inferior square I
don't know the best square dude not
alpha why would you put unite on a
square that isn't as good as the other
square the squares better yeah but you
wanted to put a pond there I didn't
alright I'll put this thing up squared
what a 93 I'm sorry that'll show you I
said C 3 because you already had the
neck though
oh alright good finally I got my double
pawns yeah waiting for so long now at
just the rest place itself okay I hate
bishops too let's see play e5 doesn't
yeah didn't like a 5 and then leg e4 e5
he's going to attack it and then you can
move here's something blow King most of
all
be reincarnated I would be a cat oh like
kittens
yeah this is exactly what would you what
would you be reincarnated yes
Danny if you could be reincarnated I
assume Danny actually has an opinion on
this if you could be reincarnated as any
dragon dragon are we restricting it to
real I don't know about them maybe
there's what I don't know though so
there's obviously a lot I don't know
might be a bear be kind of fun a bird
flying would be kind of fun I probably
wouldn't be a chicken despite my user
name on some sites uh just they live for
about two years that's just not quite
enough I don't need like full whatever
eighty human years but Oh probably a
while you know ya know I'd go for how
many things I'm detect a very strange
movie on Netflix called the lobster and
this changed my opinion about the pond
oh you didn't okay oh wait he's Danny
yeah Danny he's in the background you
never see him on camera he's like the
guy from that old Tim Allen show we just
barely see the face
[Music]
Thomas yep Thomas is still here
and yeah he'll be here again on Thursday
doing his stream yeah I thought he was
gonna be here today he told you you
could just do this yeah I don't want to
be getting crushed by dharna me this
could be him crushing Oh Jack and then
taking the check and then take and then
ah okay let's check first and then take
all night
it's 96-97 show us Danny yeah come on
and show yourself yeah it's not relation
yeah if you watch our streams enough
you'll catch a glimpse just his eyes
just barely I saw half his nose once
he's even talking to us and there's a
camera in the way it's just like peeking
over he doesn't he doesn't let you see
anything Danny is like the banker I
don't think I've ever seen Danny's full
face in real life even Danny is like the
banker on Deal or No Deal it's just the
shadowy I only ever see silhouettes oh
no Eric Rosen the spectating again
terrifying how do you know he's
spectating oh he's down here yeah hey
what's up Eric yeah you can challenge us
yeah that's the way it works all right
Rosen wants some of this we'll take them
around challenge got plenty of people to
play
all right do you fancy the French
talents I like to play it but kind of
hate the exchanged yeah but I mean it's
not like bad if you don't like equal
positions the exchange is not like the
thing to fear but it is a good reason
not to play it against the lower rated
people what's up Isaac thing about chess
you you would win against me yeah I
probably don't like equal positions it's
probably the wrong board game for you
just so for you right now ninety six six
we're killing it okay well here cos
London system videos are awesome also
learning this yet it is I give me
matters it's a tactic Lama exactly like
alpha zero early yeah we got this new
computer we also got this weird crazy
mouse yeah
yes going between us so people go to you
we got Perry Coulson in the house Perry
Coulson in this chair - yeah yeah yeah
we got Eric he's not everyone text them
felonies a coward no come on crush us
and then 8 index guy wants to play
alright yeah more 1500 are to be pretty
game you got off easy road it's tough
you know yeah I'm an additional crotch
yeah yeah I play like you since you
started playing I have enough player I
took a vacation
I learned the time enough it's not gonna
happen here Wow I also learned this line
I've never seen G theory in my life
right no in any opening every over there
just not lose it the game like I do now
what do i do I just play the time out of
anyway
right don't you alright I'm gonna do
this and this and this and this you have
a habit of putting your nighttime just
the inferior squares I don't know the
best squares do them but have sex six
they attack all the center squares yeah
you know some of a big-time Sicilian
player these days I can easily
illuminate the key ideas here after you
know I got a lot of ideas look I found
it I found a way to trade nice hopefully
over here a lot too this thing might be
hangers in it it might is it hanging no
but you can take it with just take it a
bunch alright alright I miss ya
yeah so just chillin out at the Chess
Club well you don't get checkmate it ooh
you had an intention for this guy uh one
of those squares yeah yeah they just
lined it there whichever one you think
is the worst one yeah I should have gone
to the other job they'd never able to
see that coming
never it'll come when they least expect
it mm-hmm that's the big break no one
ever sees coming but first I'll just
wait to see how this thing comes out
don't think I believe in it yeah you
know what's not the time but when you
see it you're like wow g5 also they're
like they might be listening in so you
know you're gonna be like well you
better play h4 I'm about to play g5 you
never know that could happen and then
you sound like an idiot to everybody
else talking about other words but yeah
yeah when you catch a stream sniper
you're in business all right new plan
developer stuff I thought that was the
old plan no no see all this hopping and
then dark square control and g5 just
busts it up this thing here I'm gonna
take it one day one day one day let me
just go to a threatening square right
and then and then look at this turn
again look at that
what a brilliant see hmm
attacking both the night and and
threatening to trade the night all right
who's saying bad stuff nah there's
nothing bad yeah show that one
yeah most things when it's like height
or not it's like not bad is like please
play me a bullet and then stuff just it
just gets on through you know doesn't
his guy
I thought it happened all right
someone's had the intention of
delivering my stuff maybe he can trade
though and put an idea and then I don't
know if he really wants to take that
thing but it's possible you had your
chance to answer the question do you
want to play ball it no I hate bullet
one question answer oh wait a second
I'm scared wait a second you're scared
everything just like rookie one and then
moving is trapped and then no she's not
look I got this whole diagonal on all
these squares Ricky one Queen f2 your
key TV you look like big brother and
little brother but it's not look so
alike it's kind of insane
like if I just had glasses and a beard
and dark hair and just taller and we saw
time a different part of the world then
continue maybe you that you don't care
about a Bishop c5 and fb6 and winning
Europe and so you got to play like be
six years something I'll see loser Rock
nothing right
we can't wait to second exchange the big
exchange that coming up okay it's coming
Knight takes e5 what kind the ones upon
or does it
does the Chess Club maintain a list of
chess book recommendations we do have a
quite an extensive collection of books
that we sell here and this is pretty
much everybody has their own
recommendations John Flynn you're a fan
of uh there you're mastering chess
strategy is that still my favorite oh
yeah Johan Elston so it's a nice nice
book I can't wait to start getting my
royalties on singing you can take it my
intention was to play your first do you
recommend festival at all I've never
used it Danny Machuca is a big fan I
know Danny Machuca is he is a big fan I
visited the website but I've never
actually really gone through and tried
to lanes because it's like books but
it's on you can like play through
electronically is that yeah yeah that's
kind of the idea also you can put in
your own lines of and play back through
them keep your all your opening stored
maybe a more efficient way yeah it's
pretty cool it's probably a good thing
that I should be into I just haven't
gotten into too lazy I just don't have
time anymore hey I'm too late yeah takes
takes takes takes takes
and then at the intake Hey how didn't
you lose a rug you're supposed to lose
the wreck at the end of this me yeah
yours no I'm not definitely not it's
better to just buy a book a month or
take the Premium Membership
these are Danny Machuca questions wait
can I take this tactically this takes
check now I'm gonna take end up taking a
bishop tell me no why no it just brings
us right back yeah that's why I'm asking
now my D seven now if I go seven D seven
and then you can bring the other rook in
without hanging your pawn what if I hang
my button and you take so then he takes
it and then I take this I just that's my
trick okay D seven so come on ah all
right what if I also just take this and
do this like that but you blundered I
mean it depends are you gonna read a
book a month can I take this come on
that's so funny I know a lot of people
who would buy a book a month from that
that was my trick twelve pages in that
was metric
what challenges are we taking mostly
five-o we'll see what happens as the
stream goes along but he knows yeah I
got away with my tricky
I'm so excited takes on c1 thanks thank
you square druid I'm really committed to
this trading idea mm-hmm always rated
preferred yeah I agree with what we said
on our Channel yeah our channel seems to
get me high I'm really gonna okay I'm
gonna keep playing the funny it's fine
that's it's okay
I just wanna play the funniest I don't
play good news but if I can play funny
moves ha ha it was all an elaborate
trade please don't play there dang it
[Music]
audiobooks streams into audiobooks
Senate they go back and they watch them
if you want yeah so most these are being
on our on our youtube channel that's
where they seem to end up otherwise you
can probably watch them on Twitch Jason
yeah I don't know how these things work
I just sit here lose a bunch of games of
chess say good game I didn't Dirks seems
like yeah there's the highest-rated guy
I could find you have to go oh yeah
what's we're doing is this rated this is
rated yeah where other things not rated
or am I not gaining lots of points well
we're playing 1500 to get like two
points oh sweet
why don't you play a three I'm trying
this move
it's another move I've been looking at
but that's what people do with the idea
of in this position developing my night
instead of my a3 if you want an
advantage maybe you should play Queen c2
but yeah no yeah I'm much more familiar
with other lines mm-hmm I'm just gonna
take it devote my stuff that's my
general hello over the stream and the
King says
all right I see Brian Chester running
around busy guy reminding me not to get
forked right so I'll do my best
no promises you got nervous why I'm not
even playing well why doesn't Yasser
lecture anymore he's he's more committed
to the we have so many things now where
he's here for doing commentary he'll be
here for Karen's cup he'll be here for
us champ so you know be here for
champion showdowns he'll be here for
there's like twelve GCT events now these
days so there's gonna be so much
commentary that I think that's really a
better gig for him he is open to it
though so we might get him in at some
point this year which i think would be a
really cool thing yeah it's not that he
doesn't like doing it he actually really
wants to be human res but sometimes it's
hard to schedule when we don't know the
dates of events racing we doing
commentary
everybody wants to play this which way
should I castle should i castle is a
checkmate amore castle this way and be
better well you put your knight on f3
co2 Castle kingside you don't have to
the rule I follow no I just played you
for an extra yeah he's gonna unpin just
gonna unpin just worried about I'm not
really worried about it though just
gonna take that how deep I am i read
that ideas what money is I think we're
just gonna go down the list for a bit
seems fair that way okay minority attack
you never know what I might do
hey you appreciate us we appreciate you
Chris Edwards no but now this nights
gonna magically all the way back you
fooled me
no not magically all the way back now
I'm gonna do just what I need to do just
in time I mean they play this to me why
you always just want to take everything
or just one go here bad is that Alright
yeah but you're yeah throw this one move
in yeah or the other file oh I don't
know definitely here for sure and then
this will just be confusing and then
hopefully what stronger we're gonna
calculate it we're gonna look the other
way and then we're just gonna do it do
it now it's like so complicated now I
guess that was the point right
down the list you got a challenge down
the list that's fair
LM LM that means a beach house master
it's a very prestigious title cuz I
guess they don't give it out anymore but
they gave it to us yeah yeah I think
most the stream will just be gone and
then you'll say something and I'll do it
whether it's wrong I feel like that's
how today's supposed to work hey wait a
second whoa Bishop c5 Bishop c5 might be
a strong move no he's gonna check us
he's nice
you can put a bishop there I'll still
take all right I guess we just take a
sign how exciting
now if did feel a little bit slow that
you brought your knight around and then
you have this this is a common idea of
getting the knight here to c4 but you'd
already kind of given up on that idea
when you ran away from it but now to
continue with all the natural best plans
right of threatening me over seven it is
always the most natural and the best to
try and checkmate okay got it
will do mm-hmm what could be more
natural and attacking the opponent's
king that's how you win the game
trade trade at all ah I didn't want to
that's not how you check me people right
but treating ya I mean you're up a piece
in the game no no I don't want to in the
game that I gotta play someone else
can't see the name or rating of the
opponents is this deliberate no Danny
it's Danny still back there did he'd
like go do whatever duty those I don't
know I didn't see it's a very position
on deep
mm-hmm that's strange it looks
deliberate it looks deliberate kind of
oh I see movement oh there we go
wait but then they don't know all these
strong rated players we've been crushing
this whole yeah all of them like yeah I
mean the guy was Magnus level yeah
exclam I assume his intention was to go
here take it
why I wanted to get
okay so there we go I guess now we can
kind of see it didn't work all right
just watching the unbeaten you
unbeatable your self gamers reason sweet
couldn't help but think that unless
white knew exactly what they were doing
most positions were good for black fair
assessment am i just bad no I really do
think it's it's very very pleasant for
the white I mean I'm beatable is
obviously some sort of title that Ben
Simon came up with I do really think
that it's it's good for white and black
needs to be really careful I think it's
quite the opposite all right what's up
Jesse you gonna join the stream today
all right I'll take that as a yes what
is your oh I'm Caleb Caleb done me yeah
Ben Simon does all the titles I play
this funny move only cuz this will you
yes yeah Ben Simon knows all the titles
I appreciate it cuz it seems to have
worked with that video but yeah talk
about this that's what the question they
asked you they're like are you guys
friends in real life
mmm-hmm yeah sure whatever is funnier
yeah we haven't played chess yet so I
don't know if I have to hate them in a
more of an uneasy partnership I think
it'll depend on whenever we end up
playing each other if I win or lose and
then I'll decide if I like them or not
what's my rating to I he's really strong
Caleb's good clear like 20 150 or
something yeah that's alright I think
I'm winning I wanted you to keep talking
about how great I was though until you
in that end of analysis till you let
them all fall under the below 2200 yeah
yeah we were just discussing the other
day of all of our secret plans to get
you to master somehow yeah you can have
my phone I don't care what enough so far
the the leading plan is to run away to
North Carolina and play at the Charlotte
chess center yeah so that's what a GM
told me that's apparently where the we
custom the weak flares are I asked him
where the worst chess players in the
world or if you guys know of a weaker
group of people please let us know so if
somebody here can become a master
apologies the Charlotte chest yeah don't
know him personally but but yeah let's
fight you've been called out by a
grandmaster yeah right I could go to
England but then it's tough to get a
USCF rating bump in England problem
maybe I should just skip national
mastering it get FM in a week European
country yeah I don't know Germany it's
probably a good place to do it no week
chess players are from Aruba I do feel
like it what it is really hard a lot of
people come to st. Louis and they really
get stuck in like 2150 great where
you're at yeah it's just it's just hard
it's hard around here everybody's good
only 200 around here is really tough so
you gotta like go somewhere else if
master come back and then ghost your
points back something once you get here
you start playing all those guys and go
to college and they're like yeah I'm on
Webster I'm 2450 USCF you know hmm
everyday also funny names will get you
and get you a game funny names look at
you games no and that's what somebody
just said play that person please yeah
yeah yeah funny names will take you a
long way on the stream I would stop
paying attention to people asking a
place though yes I know kind everybody
wants to place yeah we know you want to
play us this Eric Rosen guy won't leave
us alone
who is that any suggestions on how to
handle losing a winning position it
still hurts after a week yeah that's I'm
used to it what did people want to see
here everything I haven't gotten the
time on of yeah I don't think we'll keep
doing this stuff London yeah then we'll
mix it up at some point
oh come on open it up oh let's go oh oh
he's reading with the party 421 I guess
he was dreaming oh wow thanks Eric 121
views okay so I do believe kind of the
whole point of my setup though is to
play against this particular line that
that Marazzi isn't particularly good in
this line due to the pressure on here
and if you push if I go here all your
palm white squares there's like some
really funny lines I think I can I went
upon yet all of Eason hmm maybe I should
be careful think about what I'm saying
but playing with Eric I don't think Eric
wants to play us if he wants us well we
want him apparently Magnus was playing
only chess no wonder nobody's watching
us yeah all right we'll just play safe
here well yeah I do feel like this must
be okay for me hmm must be okay for me
it's okay what's the problem just
wondering if you're gonna play d5 and
that's really not to fire no development
pieces that's pretty much all it takes
to get to 95th percentile overall like
you do not need to be as good as people
think you do hmm
that's when I'm out here just to
celebrate you know a lot of people they
think you must be pretty good to get to
a class it's just not true
I develop my pieces and castle it's not
fair well I've come up with a funnier
username and I'll play first yes the way
it is I mean there's other ways those
obviously other people with not funny
names we're gonna be playing but I saw
it so I had to click on it Fabiano draw
I wanna all right so the list of things
to watch on a chest runs magnus carlsen
and then us
usually there's TCC up there with like
400 or something well that's all cuz of
Eric so ya big thanks to mr. Rosen for
given us the huge raid we should get
into the rating business we yeah we
should you should see see what's up
after reasonable amount of viewers you
know he helped someone hooked us up with
maybe wasn't maybe hook Eric up in the
future yeah I just get Eric to start
streaming in
we'll just yeah yeah yeah we're gonna go
till about for another what is it half
hour an hour I don't know how long we're
stupid today but anyway but whatever it
is just get Eric back on well give him
right back hopefully we can maintain
however many he sent our way to
overstuff six attacking upon no just
developing her so she's defending upon
stern player developer stuff okay sure
pun was on d5 I love my stuff first
that's the natural in of like eighty six
before g5 because just that professional
yeah okay but only after h3 because just
show that we're both on the same level
of professionalism just shoving the
Queen up there yeah me there's one
always puns you can take like you get
like checkmated usually you're just
going way out there usually you get like
checkmated gonna get way over there and
then like they can go over there and
check me any tips how to get better at
chess above 2150 no that's how far kill
of could take you oh yeah he actually
teaches the the road to 2000 class here
yeah coming to YouTube tomorrow Oh
exciting guys tomorrow at 6:30 yes so
yes they probably got that premier thing
I never had one of my things do a
premier yeah oh yeah yes be cool dare
you
hmm constantly playing some competition
and analyzing all of your losses who's
that oh this rosin yeah
also here's a font that from this angle
I just can't read I guess he's been
talking for a while I just can't read
that that's him
I can fix that I don't think it's his
actual font I think it's just on the
screen for me right now there's the
setting and I have no idea why it isn't
enabled by fault
by default this is readable golden
colors oh there we go I think oh I'll
take a readable color as opposed to
unreadable colors yeah okay this is too
complicated for me I don't like your
position yeah you know ephors weak King
I don't know all right put that on the
ideal space yeah everyone go watch
Rosen's videos don't watch this game
take a take a break from watching this
game because in case it ends poorly and
go watch Rosen videos coming back Sierra
alright see Erica
hard stuck on a rink too well that guy's
name is Fabiana Capablanca Wow was a
real real chess player right there
sounds too strong
okay Oh trade and King g7 or trade I
would never I'm not a traitor I don't
believe that for a second I love
training uh-huh something like that
might happen if you didn't trade and
then what's the problem
and then what's the word I mean we're
gonna lose upon and it gets some lower a
player in this one he's playing well
stop you guys are supposed to make it
easy for me up man I'm at work I don't
want to be working come on don't make me
work for it okay I'm going I'm going
alrighty there this came out five got
played no I wasn't sure it would happen
no oh no can't take that no he does have
a thing you got four
yeah this is king of the hill today
wasn't it you're close what variant is
US where does it say
funnier moves please yeah I know King at
five it's kind of funny yeah back back
back back run away it's not what the
people want
you know how to play above 2,900 I don't
feel like this panel of people it's well
qualified to answer that question yeah
go watch the alpha0 debate with Jacob
Balkans if you want to learn about that
yeah that's a good point you hear those
but I was really popular - so what's
glad to see that got a lot of use I will
give you a biscuit
if you beat bristle for business maybe
mr. drawn I found that perpetual oh no
we're so winning he's getting crushed
and now I will give you biscuit if you'd
be risk it for biscuit wow I don't know
what that means but I'm intrigued I'm
slightly can crush like slightly there's
a small amount of this position that
feels losing right I don't feel like a
little bit I might be losing like a
little bit please use a three you know
made here oh no no no no made for sure
everything that's covered why would you
say that fact I'm just winning down to
pawns for the initiative stop I was
expecting night of seven and like g4 or
something was probably probably I mean
this if we escape yes no we are winning
Oh super winning really really really
winning your pond where you defended it
I got lucky
Anish would have drawn yeah you had your
chance for the big draw
hey check which one stop playing so well
one place slightly slower - no I think
we are winning explosive prawn tempura
if you beat hit car when a Kimura
alright so I'm not getting that but what
was the other thing I had a chance that
well this is it one biscuit yes that's
what I need in my life a biscuit I
played so well double on the seven Wow
by the seventeen me in a second I did
exactly what I need no drunk come on
which one check the rope oh no point two
seconds oh god alright alright finally I
know too tough for me you guys think
about big we got that one four minutes
um yeah he had a bed
I don't think he's officially retired
but he's gonna keep playing you know
there's a name now there's a name look
at that name he how did you play you
played great you played like way better
than these fantastic yeah you played too
good for me
oh you GED I've decided not to take
immediately which is the only thing I
know mmm but I'm gonna try this new
strategy of developing my stuff yeah
don't trust it yeah you're right back to
basics you tend to say anything those
things that's been playing the time in
all his life I'm just trying to get so I
guess I did play it right I can cross
that off the list now I have to play the
anymore yeah all right good well no some
people wanted something I just know this
one silly stupid maneuver is that the
move could be then there's like some
brilliant move here I'm just
her stuff where anyway do I want him to
play that move eventually well right now
would be great but do it like later deep
do you explain the deep dependent I'll
play the opening and then you explain
all the depth spend so much you want to
play it before like 30 years that
thing's defended he's gonna do that okay
take on c5 audience needs yes yeah stick
around he'll be here in a few days
yeah no yeah very soon all right so
what's happening here
the dark squares my winning game crushed
tell me what's happening
mmm probably like be 394 and then that's
game are you guys fav players official
Club answer is Fabi does he's officially
our favorite
play Evans gambit all right I hate to
lose my pawn slow seems to happen when
you play that ones gambit all right um
you see any plans that's okay
hello J Matthew what's up
that guy's name is Andy friends actually
and friends and there's my first name
friends that's my last name
good close though
why are man in my shoes
my mother said advised me not to answer
that question I say this of my own free
will
nobody is forcing me Fabiana Cara Juana
is everyone's favorite player
watch every sto video if you play me you
watch all of them that's loud well we
better not play that game Zeus we make
up my vastra you go watch some gutter
but will still play you it's like a hour
a day got to take up a twentieth this
guy's like what I do if I face Magnus I
don't try my hardest and loose
now for the best move but you can't play
a three and we're probably sucks will
challenge the world champ next hopefully
finally anything I'll be someone totally
different then I came on he planned this
one that's okay we don't care then we
plan something well no take me to high
just take it
uh-huh just take it ah haha it's
defended you woo you got lucky guy
no this thing's attacked yeah you better
move it to a square at the best square
yeah that's the best way Nakamura is
beast
yeah we like him but not as much as is
more impressive than Caruana anybody
asks our second Wesley so but maybe he's
tied with Nakamura what if my name is
actually magnus carlsen you guys pick
for the Super Bowl
I like the Patriots wait we're from st.
Louis
kind of a heartbreaking matchup here Tom
Brady he's pretty good it's hard to say
Tom Brady he's not gonna win a Super
Bowl
he just doesn't it's not gonna was Super
Bowl doesn't work
why not just doesn't work dude my bishop
singing he takes it so he takes it mean
- I mean he takes it than I don't have
it yeah so
you know maybe I don't know what's your
threat Bishop c4 and then found a threat
I only know one idea Fabi is way better
than naka in classical Tingler in is
your favorite player yeah good to see
you
photon is it's a photon I can't read
from this runway photon man what's on
man yeah ding super good play right now
h3 I need to find like a good move here
I just don't see it
screaming okay sort of gonna lose the
thread if I sort of stopped paying
attention for a second here it's
probably not the right don't you ever
feel like you wasted so many years on
chess and stopped on a mediocre level
yeah all the time I mean you know
who doesn't I mean it got me this far
now you guys are watching me just
randomly pass my pieces around what was
your highest rating ever moves in the
mid to high 1,900 range
mid to high are you still trying oh yes
I told Jonathan from national mastered a
grandmaster
yes I'm like that um no a master would
be if be a like it's like a lifetime ago
getting to expert would be nice
I'd be just as good as Caleb yeah that's
and then that would make Caleb sad
propelling him to become a master feel
like that's often what actually inspires
people it's like that guy reading no the
fork was not quite working we forked the
rocks he gets two pieces from one rook
that's not good
I'm just gonna keep attacking his Rick's
one time look I already have another way
to attack his rook one time it's great
no move the King hopefully if I have a
good night jump ET here Knight c5 the
knight straps it's trapped it's almost
no way it's a pretty it'd be pretty cool
I mean it could move anywhere if I take
it he takes player well I have to check
and then you calculate it every by
anywhere you meant a2 then yeah anyway
93 was a bet for another check where
which one more checks I don't see any
tricks which one just keep hopping every
nights keep checking it Oh somehow my
back rank something bad
it's true what happened time mister
check wait a minute I see you know
attraction check you have played your
xe5 just to confuse them
no it's true have a check check then a
rook check there's a deep level stuff
here okay wreck check more rook attacks
wait a second
and we want a pawn where why don't you
take his Knight - I'm moving fast I'm
trying to flag to become Grandmaster you
need to know how to jumpity jump with
the night correctly yeah yeah they teach
you this I Grandmaster school sentence
kind of yes
since it's gonna hurt to read gimme oh
we finally did it
well you knew it was coming come on we
just didn't know when like what's
happening though I just king d yeah that
one hopefully oh yeah I know
night-night a - so I want this truck
yeah no 91-92 King D - King D - this is
draw yeah or no yeah now calculate
calculate H 4 that's not you didn't
calculate that h4 no that doesn't work
does it yeah this is really working are
you joking
let's draw okay
this is your intention we'll wait hold
on well now this is great for us oh yeah
no we win and I take with the question
was a big teddy with take this take with
well the h-bomb no the F pawn he's
saying lol in the chair yep on the yet
pawn you don't wanna give me the outside
passed pawn okay
yeah hopefully people can't read his
chat that's kind of funny though so the
question was alright thank you for the
game the question was if you just played
like King and won again
like King EE to King anyone yeah yeah
yeah right you should just keep going
here right if you play King b3 or we
like wait you slow
wait I assume we're way too slow like I
don't think is even close
yeah I don't think it was just like
ahead of us yeah thank you for game my
name is not Andy friends stop saying
that okay
let's tone it down he's a good-looking
gentleman besides Jonathan I didn't know
where that was going
it's one of a hide you must be me
I'm Caleb Caleb Denby yeah also a
big-time streamer famed streamer in
lecture at the singles Chess Club well
that's the other thing we need Caleb to
that go right after us too because then
we could read you or we can write Eric
we have people yeah I just learned what
a rate is so now I'm into it always here
though this is like he's supposed to be
wrong for some reason but nobody knows
why okay zero people into i0 can I take
this no good to know
that's good hey don't get forked serious
it was a rain Chester serious Chester
masterminds venting everyone from
getting worked across I haven't been for
sense other than the last Raider game I
played why you know sometimes you get
before 20 play games especially the
nights not after the series though well
f tournament I don't want to talk about
what happened in round three I was gonna
sack my pond brilliantly mmm super
brilliant
somehow you gonna have one of my buns
take one of something she probably win
right no take one of my bonds okay
alright Eric Mosel pond you're gonna
join us you want to get a little camera
time alright yeah nights are better in
clogged up positions I agree I'm just
gonna play like a crazy guy tonight I
don't know why I want it to be down upon
so bad but I just had the feeling
they're also just great I wasn't joking
about that move in Blitzen bullet
because nobody knows how they moved this
chat still working come on where do
people stop talking to us anyone's
talking on YouTube now well you know
it's a really awesome night SEC I'm not
sure about that pond sack though hmm I
just want it to be down to five I don't
know it was just like eternal like I
just I didn't want it maybe through the
last turn but we definitely should be
through this tune he thought it was lame
because it was the queen queen of
stripped it was now we're super nut
trapped it was definitely not on the net
floor and then doesn't sound right to me
I don't know I just feel like a caveman
today don't tell him yeah no I I played
one good Gibson I just feel like I have
to play back in it's a tough question
because all 1,600 players do not play
the same way some need to focus on
tactics some need to focus on hey how'd
you see that each eye management some
need to focus on not falling asleep at
the board that's the artist that one is
very difficult
all right haven't told them but I have
to keep defending my bishop which is
just part of the trophy takes to rock
you do this at night and then yeah
participant that mate so it's not yeah
that's good I knew I'd be I knew I could
play one bad game I had a bad game in me
like the way fast
hi dannion friends Oh cheesy chess
anything yeah a lot of people aren't
here to see Danny so only they could see
him I've never even seen him no good
opening videos but I'm an e4 player yeah
probably
most of my videos would d4 it's not
really wasn't attention it was probably
more of an e4 player at the time when I
made all these videos Queen f3
yeah one of the 3f buns yes sir everyone
look for yo sir they shouldn't space
they tuned early February see it's a
good move how do emotes work at some
point in my life I'm gonna figure it out
that's a Jess bra emo okay so was he
subscribed to chess brah so we can post
any mode everywhere okay so if you
subscribe
do we have one for us well it's my note
I don't actually remember we do we have
to we got to we've got the Magnus Shh
oh the iconic yeah yeah yeah and we've
got infinity plus a ton from the famed
st. Louis said that always plays oh nice
and then some people can just put those
yeah everywhere but you have to be a
subscriber Magnus has never been a
better time to subscribe I'm getting the
big thumbs up from our subscriber guy
a third need some ideas you made them
yourself
you wanna come talk about it on the
stream that's alright
anything to distract from this position
game over his opponent has trysil on
ease yeah yeah yeah alright do I get to
resign yet sure people want to see you I
don't know what they're all so this one
is No all right thanks for the game you
played well I played we risk it for
biscuit all right this is an important
one but yeah you come here and talk so I
can I can really focus here on mr.
biscuit focus mode I'm in focus mode all
right who are you and what do you do
I've done you made that you made this I
don't even know Ana mode really is hold
on what does he need a mic speak into
this oh oh I'm just speaking blindly
here hello people of Earth
check clip it on like the Ballad of
Ricky Bobby yes so I'm the developer or
web developer for the st. Louis chess
club and I help out with the twitch
channel
Yeah right now we just have to emoticons
like so the infinity plus a ton from you
guys still not here
alright can you hear now that was a
while ago
okay so good sorry to slow down you mean
you know yes and we also have the magnet
fishing icon which is that's my personal
favorite but I think we can have at
least three okay something like that
yeah it's based on its it's based on the
number of yeah the based on the number
of subscribers I assume everyone on
Twitch are teen okay so it's how many
subscribers we have on Twitch yeah and I
think if we really wanted to I think we
could pay to have a couple more but it's
not something that we've really needed I
guess or really spend time developing so
if there's the after suggestions for
them we would gladly take them I think
it's kind of neat because people can do
particular things we can do things
unique to our channel okay which I don't
know yeah would be I guess a st. Louis
emoticon would be kind of me Fabiano
emot-- yeah not freaking Magnus nice
emotes crushing it feel like actually
was meant to Castle there and then I
feel like there's a lion like I Castle
when they check and I move and they go
here that's someone I played it
different will pretend to confuse our
opponent are you giving away your
strategy while playing oh god see well
it's a bad one so it doesn't really
matter how only confuse okay now this
person is gonna give me a biscuit
personally that's what I'm hoping for
if I win so there's a lot on the line
okay so we can get more votes so we get
more subscribers and then how do people
use them how do i I've never used in a
moat how do I use it so you can use them
on I use one right now yeah you can use
this clear click directly click this or
you can type what did you click code you
clicked on this little spawn
or you can just type in STLCC infinity
ton I don't know if we're subscribed to
ourselves we should be able to drop
anything motive cons that we have it's
like we're subscribed
oh thank goodness and I think they're
all I think but it's like us we don't
just I think we can also gift
subscriptions to people like if
someone's super duper awesome like so we
can we can pay to have subscribers yeah
with infinite money you can just have
infinite subscribers and be the number
one to subscribe oh yeah well we can
make as many as we want a lot of work to
do this guy's playing with like idea
we've talked about maybe having a st.
Louis emoticon right now whenever you
subscribe you get a little badge change
okay I think if you subscribe for one
month you get one color and then three
months and we'll do all the way up to
like a couple years or something so yeah
so it's really noticeable if you go into
like the chats brazos channel because
they have subscribers for however many
long and you get magical wow gold horse
icons there's people to subscribe yes
it's kind of a neat thing to so then
people can know how long you've you've
been a part of the community in whatever
yeah exactly so I think that's kind of
cool right now I think there's just the
two levels there's like we have like one
month in three months and I think we
there's only a handful of people in
three months like us and might come or
maybe Bensimon I think I think he has
one for whatever reason and he has a mod
sword he's a pod sword yeah okay yeah
yeah whatever your moderator get the
sword yeah okay so you can ban people
yes all right
what were you guys saying about me Ben
do you only play chess or possibility of
receiving biscuits it's an incentive
that I I do take very seriously
good come on does this work
did I win tell me that I won please
to answer for a draw no that's somewhere
Cytron all right think something
something's good here now something is
good something it's here it's good
why don't you just push our buns like
push it yeah and then v6 and then you're
Brooks are in and then you win and then
in here why would he not go there well
then you'll take it yeah but this is now
someone's good here for me I just can't
can't feel it out in the GM in his heart
this one feels like I should never be
allowed to get this big break in I mean
I am supposed to be I am so close only
like seven years of dedicated time and
studying talents
no master obviously is super super
realistic you obviously should be
focused on being master national master
is a lot easier than international
master yeah give you the same chess
advice everyone else gave me give up yes
yes I wish I would have taken that a
long time friends I wouldn't I wouldn't
be here suffering against the people
this is one of the best okay
always retreat yep that's true too
okay he's going on that way I was going
here hmm
don't allow trip T - don't let it play
it don't let them do it it's impossible
to prevent impossible
he had one trick just makes so many
clean how many check fine I knew that
was check how many oh hey you didn't
tell me he had at one check more than
one no queens you said which one Oh both
at the same time which was the accurate
one
oh it just Auto cleaned oh no what if I
wanted to not out okay give me another
chance
I'm making a queen I guess meeting for
what Mike is meeting for this guy into a
game thank you risk it for biscuit you
can send your biscuit in the mail to the
Chess Club yeah too weak too slow no he
played great actually yeah it was
actually really interesting opening its
another thing I'm studying now so I
didn't even play the opening well down
this list here it's guy night that
sounds good nothing really like your
opening videos will you make some new
ones this year no plans just getting
into streaming and stuff I get I could
on the stream I guess to do some opening
stuff I guess that's probably my best
chance at getting opening stuff out
there in the world all right you're a
big E for player these days right yeah
so this is not the time on up this is
the con right there for me that I have
no idea where in the middle a
crash-course and opening know this guy
Big E for a player these days
yeah all day yesterday he was an e4
player so I don't only read the first
page of the night or book okay we
appreciate your dedication of the Chess
Club I know the mainline just tell me
the the typical ideas in this opening
for me only one I know is checkmate
that's USAC no checkmate come on
checkmate him oh come on
checkmate he's not over there yet though
it might not be checkmate but if you
played f5 is that too dumb no no no yeah
whatever I've always seen these
professional people they bring this
thing in and then somehow this thing
swings over and then somehow checkmate
right and I never bring this piece in
but now that I'm super strong about
bringing all my pieces in should be an
easy win
I'm gonna go hear something something
yeah we're happy to see you too we don't
know this person personally usually
doesn't want to Castle queenside but
sometimes he hangs around in the center
of the board sometimes it's all logic
yeah now for whatever the typical
checkmating attack pattern is I'll
demonstrate it don't worry about it he
five is slightly he's defended slightly
he's a pro yeah this here are you insane
you lose Mike takes it you take it back
and then they take it with the night
yeah thanks what then they take it the
bishop
probably
you play g6 nevermind yeah what if he
didn't play g6 that I can take this
alright good calculating now some other
moves yeah good good that's that's my
advice
yeah just listen to the high rate of
guys the pawns those are we just need
this one night we're gonna be the this
guy's gonna be star of the show here
Murph in ski
we won that yeah we'll say that we're
2020 yeah yeah we started like nineteen
something so yeah making progress today
slowly but surely what time is this
treatment is it actually over right now
okay let's play one more game after this
and then we'll just rev it up
don't waste too much of Jesse's time
he's got whatever just there's stuff to
do sites to web hmm didn't see that
coming Charlie strong it's a good chess
player I'm playing that's tech something
wants what don't be played well he's the
best so
I don't believe it for him
nope nothing gets played well it's
probably only because I am more likely
to have black on this position so it's
kind of biased dolls played sound
sacrifices which engines approve of yeah
I don't do that Knight takes c6 looked
scary yeah but I thought maybe I'd be
giving up a knight for two pawns and
thought maybe that's bad no idea that
was a black and white stream but Ron
says red shirt makes all the difference
yeah thank you very much I busted out
the red today this is a Cinco Cup 2014 I
won't be able to find these anymore
Oh am i I like the bright blue ones
though there's something better anywhere
everyone that's in the Chess Club across
the street who's getting Forks the most
near him dang it
I was hoping he would somehow stop my
fork and then only then formulator when
I had time to prevent it too and then
just clean my mop material it's pretty
great so how this opening works use win
material yes
slow grind you got
jack-jack is stronger jack is the
stronger tell me if that's but I wanna
go here first where I wanted to go here
first you know he might take with the
bishop I'll take a little piece you
might see I'll take first and then yeah
I'm paying attention to this trust me
I'm not over here hold on make sure to
hang your queen you had to allow this is
inaccurate because you didn't play your
opponent well enough okay get in there
yep if you want somebody give Queens
away willy-nilly I'm your man that's
true we should let Jessie physician
staff tournament three you know did you
did you lose your queen all three games
all three games I'm not like with no no
tip material game didn't see it coming
Oh Oh that pawn got my queen oh it was
and you played in both staff tournaments
right the last two at least yeah I guess
I guess I didn't look I probably want to
talk about it yeah where I protected it
dude
well it just doesn't count as cheating
what are we doing this cheating advising
opening theory and Correspondence games
I don't know what revising opening
theory actually means though maybe means
reviewing opening theory yeah most sites
they let you consult an opening database
and even like sometimes an endgame
database which feels a little bit shady
here to me okay like you can use just
endgame you can use a table base and on
a lot of sites which I learned do that
was kind of like yeah that feels closer
to cheating than using
can you correspondence yeah it's pretty
draw games right to play objectively the
best moves and then like you know go
really deep on certain positions and
figure out you know okay this is what
happens
some people don't play like that
obviously some people just want to play
chess the weird you know in a slow and
painful manner not doing this right
oh well yeah what can you do fireworks
display okay now we got them right where
you know all of that for this which is
still probably good for me so this
should work out for me go away don't go
away
no just you can I go here now probably
you just yeah yeah all right Thank You
sky night so yeah I guess we'll do one
more and then we'll call it a day here
last game in the street yes we'll call
it a day and we'll play a long one
because this is a funny name and that's
all it takes
there you go Turkish Joni sins let's do
it just make it a 14-day promote or
something okay but yeah we more or less
than a successful day here no matter
what happens against Turkish Johnny here
so so what's the record 2020 so we're at
2028 now yeah nice yeah yeah slowly
making progress and then it is the
chance tomorrow
I guess Wednesday at 3:00 we get Ryan
Chester in here so is your chance to
take our points away Thursday it gets
tough again this the GM then they'll
just rank that rating back up and just
crank it up and then you know someone
else will get to tear it down he took
that right away yeah Thursday's is a
tough day but obviously if you want to
play Jim that's the day to play
I assume Ryan's doing it tomorrow but
you never know it could be anybody is he
our classical guy what's our classical
rating feel like I've lost that pawn
before I think he's already start star
talk guy
that's true if you don't know what the
stars holds near future and you only
want to know from our own me and
subscribe
yay finally that's what we were waiting
for notes yes we're just waiting for one
subscriber so that we can you know
called a stream of success who's GM and
res so it's a ton of coal left it'll be
here on Thursday seems a bit weird what
he's doing I like your lectures on
YouTube Jonathan thank you very good
teacher and a nice guy oh that part some
of those words yeah
hey it's critic student I wish we didn't
get the chance to play today Kramnik
it's true yeah yeah that's good to see
her
almost Super D kramnik student prep I
can pretend to have down the drain
that's how I so I spend most of my time
prepping for him
tossing it down the drain yeah for what
and what I've thought about maybe I
should just like common people that I'm
gonna play oh my Wow very generous thank
you so much choice it it's a lot who
kramnik enjoys this retirement we better
you got to win now high pressur
situation he lose yeah what do you need
whatever he wants for five subs will win
or lose whatever you want in the game
tell me losing is easier than winning
but we send the biscuit we want to
kramnik student for chromatic student I
would send him a biscuit they offer only
extends to chromatic student nobody else
we know which one I was I was thinking
of going here with the same time yeah
but I was farther away so you know I
also Tex d5 this way so does this kind
of harder to see where you guys for your
videos how'd you enjoy him OD fine yeah
some random move now I heard a long time
ago from a very good chess player in
chess you can do this yeah if you're
watching in if you're watching on the
YouTube chat you will sadly not be able
to use twitch emotes presumably is there
something similar on YouTube is there
anything close to I think you can do I
don't think there's like a paid
subscription like on twitch there's
something that some popular youtubers
have now or even like you know join the
community and then
kind of the same thing but interesting
yeah there are super chats on YouTube
what's super chat basically you pay a
little bit of money and then your
message shows up at the top for a long
time it's very exciting
that's super yeah that's where the super
comes in and super chat wasn't just say
we got to figure out this rating thing
do you know how to read people
great yeah I can find somebody do you
know do you know how to do it we need to
be logged than the actual account place
oh yeah Danny how do we read people log
into the account we might be here also
who do we like the most
also I'm quickly even though I know this
is on our thing nobody else is on the HS
at least yeah nobody's featured guys
speaking French hopes he can play decent
chests tonight you just gonna pick some
random person usually unless we know
something I don't recognize really
anybody I want a pond okay pick someone
but he's too successful yeah you can
pick somebody that's new is yeah do a
good thing so how do you raids work so
you have to be logged into the actual
account or you have to change your
settings around so other accounts can do
it somebody's somebody swim tooling
somebody in our game and then all you
have to do is use your name you know
that okay but you're not logged in down
our thing enough nope have to be
somewhere right
not on this computer Danny is Danny you
login is us who yeah yeah just tend to
that guy um news wins wins or whoever
you want whatever yeah you can pick
where I can go I do want to see how it
works read King crusher to raid Kings
pressure on
me yeah yeah but I want to see how I
want to see what the rain looks like I
just don't know it looks like well
you'll see it from the viewers point of
view yeah no it's not the same except
for a few of their Channel right now
yeah all right hopefully everything is
fine for me I took some puns hoping for
the best
here you know so there's this annoying
pinch if I move my night away he's gonna
take my room that part's annoying
somehow I can maybe save this thing you
gotta take his robe back some point you
might take this one
you might just take my phone yeah let's
see what he does with us right first
Danny can make laptops account a
supermoon ya know it's kind of weak so
we got people like you know Lama Lord
and Danny they kind of know what's going
on on the twitch Isaac's pretty good at
which we got Jesse Richardson you know
holding it down he seems to know stuff
he knows how to make emotes you know
didn't motives me neither but I make
them but yeah you got a pretty good crew
here
I love your positive teaching lecture
style thank you very much
I can't see the other chat so if you're
talking in YouTube right now
unfortunately I don't know what you're
saying
but uh do we get it all figured out we
did now does it show something on our
page
yes it'll show up there where exactly no
sorry chat the real view yeah yeah sorry
Chet I can't see you anywhere unless I
can
Isaac Caleb and Dennis closed not quite
yeah yeah instead of Dennis since Danny
well wait maybe this is from a previous
day or something no that'd be funny too
yeah somebody's reading this 1500 yeah
wait am I here I could have taken this
bishop maybe yeah I wasn't paying
attention
max you can bet on is a draw check Oh No
[Music]
yeah poor Turkish journey since it was a
tough battle
snacker Feist hmm what's the funniest
move and you want go go to Queen all
right well yeah thank you guys everybody
thanks photon man everybody else is in
the chat can't see everybody's name
Roberto bilious some other names I can't
read theirs is that what it's yeah
Wednesday 3:00 p.m. Central Time so come
back tomorrow it'll be a little bit more
action here and thanks everybody for
watching